Oh
[Music]
Channing Tatum posted this hilarious
shot of his daughter Everly's makeup
masterpiece quote what it looks like
when a little tyrant fairy artist holds
you down and makes your face look better
I love it those are some good parents
right there
but we know mom Jenna has her own beauty
tips to share obviously you have to do
this in combination with working hard
Jenna Dewan Tatum does pool beam lasers
to tighten the skin on her tummy and her
secret for flawless tone legs a cocktail
of shimmer makeup
Madonna makes 59 looked like 39 by doing
pork facial skin mom of three Jessica
Alba uses this $69 tool to tighten and
improve skin tones like keeps up and
massages your skin you go under here
which is my favorite thing to do
giving your face a little workout and
Trisha Yearwood
well she recently tried goat yoga when
you're when you're in that position you
know there's a goat on you I did have to
go home and explain some scratches and
some hoof marks but you know what grass
was fine with it
so what are some other celeb secrets on
how to slay Pilates devotee Kate Hudson
does collagen protein smoothies Halle
Berry works out with her superhot
trainer but Gwyneth has tried all sorts
of non-traditional beauty treatments
from steaming her lady parts to bee
stings to get rid of inflammation the
bee sting has all this amazing healing
properties not really painful of course
I've been using light stem so there are
these little lasers that I hold to my
face at home there's one light that's
for front and wrinkles and like sun
damage adds up and there's another one
to kill bacteria that cause back pain
I've been wrapped in foil because I
heard that like it was supposed to detox
your body of like any aluminum and like
blah blah blah I felt hot and sticky and
I wanted to take a shower that's what I
haven't done this but I really want to
try the pedicure with the fish but eat
the dead skin stars like Mandy Moore
Demi Lovato and the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills have tried cryotherapy Hey
the treatment is said to burn 800
calories in three minutes but maybe the
most interesting beauty tip we've heard
comes from Sandra Bullock use
preparation-h to get rid of under eye
lines and bags
apparently models use it apparently they
use it they put in the fridge I've never
used it if you want to put butt cream on
your face I say you put that Bucknam on
your face confession I've used it me Oh
does it really work though it works
really it does okay well now it's gonna
work out that all women can agree on to
get in spring break yeah and some are
too bikini season is upon us it is
called body by Simone
[Music]
[Applause]